[Musique]
je voulais te présenter mes condoléances
et aux marques
on était à l'école tous les deux et le
6e
si jamais tu veux qu'on soit si tu as
besoin d'une épaule pour pleurer en
métro ou en train de me draguer l'or qui
à peine deux secondes en enterrer mon
homme
voici ma carte
[ __ ] je rêve comment est-ce qu'un mec
comme marc a pu gagner 20 millions
une femme cupide comme toi pour soulager
un gros bouillon en l'occurrence marc de
la moitié tremblay tu veux dire
l'épousé qu'on se prenne un pot tous les
deux ce soir je n'attends qu'un petit
mot de toi
[Musique]
ma beauté il y en a plus pour longtemps
bientôt leur changera nous où cette
fille est une merde
est-ce que tu servait une table à la
place vous pouvez me faire deux grands
kebab supplément harissa et suppléments
rails
[Musique]
jusqu'où tu vas aller j'irais aussi loin
qu'il le faudra
je crois que la vengeance n'est pas la
solution tu n'en sera pas récompensé
[Musique]
vous maroilles wind consentez vous
apprendre qu nicholson pour légitime
épouse daisy mollo avec bon ça c'est
quoi un jaguar blanc de presse que 180
kg j'ai enfin toucher le [ __ ] de gros
lot au [ __ ] de gros lot doit recevoir
l'aval et au plus offrant
ça fait du bien de voir des visages amis
des commandos marine
vous êtes en état d'arrestation pour
crimes contre l'humanité on peut
souffrir de convulsions subite ma radio
restera allumée h 24 noms sortent alors
[ __ ] merde là encore cherche est un
mercenaire surentraînés un tueur
professionnel
leurs fleurs a laissé sortir la plupart
des animaux il suit le meilleur des
entraînements militaires
il suffirait tirer sur sa laisse point
ramené n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits où
peut se cacher il a dit qu'il allait se
cacher je pars à la chasse le
gouvernement le vivant
alors pourquoi franck
rien ne me ferait plus plaisir que de
faire équipe avec toi fais chaque fois
plus tard
[Musique]
si vous voyez le pleure vous le futé ça
vaut aussi pour le jaguar vous tuer mon
geste je vous défonce le crâne c'est
clair
j'ai une très chouette cage qui t'attend
[Musique]
mon dieu protège papa et brigitte
patrick et bernadette et même andrew
protège weeber où ils woerth et tous les
chevaux pour cet événement de la mer
[Musique]
tu prête pas part je veux aller en
groupe
je veux être meilleur bonjour je suis
michèle fait je suis choqué et libre
pour un travail de cavaliers de piste
j'attends dehors si vous avez besoin de
moi
il lui faut plus qu'un manager est une
femme jockey pas si mal que ça tu fais
quoi après la course
champagne
prince of rain dance avec licha est en
route pour la course
une fille d'un grand jamais bon coeur
[Musique]
j'ai déjà perdu ma femme et une fille
l'espace ratisse et humain
il faut que je montre ce cheval une
autre blessure à la tête pourrait être
fatal je pourrais remonter quand c'est
une course très périlleuse il faut
beaucoup de courage penser que ce n'est
qu'une question de force
il s'agit de bien plus important que ça
[Musique]
j'ai une chance je sais que ce cheval en
est à son comble pour cet événement de
label bang
[Musique]
et c'est exactement ce qui remonte lui
inventer
[Musique]
la seule chose qui compte ce sont les
chances que tu vas te donner
[Musique]
si seulement on avait des traits de
pâques
[Musique]
et là arrive le moment qui doit arriver
il loue le truc ya quoi une tête fois
mais c'est pas si vous imaginez le
cataclysme si tu viens on va tous les
français quel dommage et là je déclenche
mon accouchement rendement je le jure
c'était un vrai scénario de la maison
620 ce que j'aime bien
[Musique]
photo jonathan connue raconte une
histoire elle est incroyable ok mais
après je raconte mon histoire c'est
celle de fiennes saut et franchement
c'est un truc de dingue d'accord dans
mon histoire
vous désirez déjeuner non c'est gentil
merci monsieur dans mon oreille on a une
choucroute de la mer sur son lit pour
simple après qu'un peu me mettais en 6
merci au revoir donc dans mon histoire
je tombe secondes
c'est peut-être important les garçons sa
mort de koné garcia je suis tellement
donc dans mon histoire
en fait ça va encore on me raconte une
histoire où apparemment il revient à
commencer donc si tu peux moi pareil
hier j'ai vu julie gayet la voile c'est
une amie elle m'a raconté une anecdote
mon poste j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
oui il arrive on s'appelle on s'appelle
quelqu'un m'appelle il arrivait
justement il arrive vous avez su que je
parte avec tessinois mais pas du tout
pas du tout tu peux rester donc je te
disais dans mon histoire
j'ai vite je dois retrouver cyprien
c'est une urgence
ludovic tu as une minute j'écoute ton
histoire il faut que tu sois court et
concis
donc
excusez moi il est midi comme chaque
jour à la même heure nous allons
observer une minute de silence en la
mémoire de johnny hallyday ou nous
manque tellement soir
[Musique]
j'ai vu quelque chose que j'étais pas
censé voir alors ils ont envoyé deux
gars pour nous descendre
georgia je suis allé me cacher à paris
depuis ce jour là ça mais il faut que tu
sortes qu'ils fassent quelque chose du
passé au comptant sur internet tu
découpes tous ces articles de journaux
tu les as semble quoiqu'il en soit c'est
fini
georgia
à
cf
il faut que je sache que tu cherches
fois ci c'est la même personne
georgia georgia
[Musique]
samedi nick catherine c4 maintenant ça
peut paraître simple et je crois que
georges elle confie georgia est morte
dans la sentir
je crois qu'elle a complètement changé
de look est qu'il s'est teint les
cheveux et l'a enlevé ses tatouages et
se fait appeler lorraine clair que vous
êtes survient ça suffit je sais pas qui
vous êtes
on se connaît c'est moi le gars mais
qu'est ce que t'as foutu je suis ici de
l'apec
retrouvez ici ils peuvent venir trouver
n'importe où
oh
[Musique]
annuler l'opération tu cherches à
m'intimider
je voudrais tout simplement une réponse
[Musique]
elle était une photo ta nouvelle
conquête souhaite montrer une photo ojlt
crois moi tu n'oublieras pas s'est
ravitaillé par les corbeaux ici ou quoi
ben mon vieux c'est quoi ça c'était un
avion de chasse
c'est trop petit pour un avion tu sens
cette chaleur avez vous déjà vu quelque
chose de semblable
[Applaudissements]
tu la mets lors tout va bien o o
doucement
et qu'est ce qui se passe les gars ont
fait pour vous a ramené une petite
surprise
il a grossi depuis qu'on l'a rapporté
selon vous qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
[Musique]
et il me montre des choses auraient
est ce que quelqu'un ici peut me dire ce
qui se passe
tu te feras pana
[Musique]
gb
professeur lorsque vous faites face à
l'inconnu vous vous éloignez du vide
vous vous plongez
[Musique]
non
cadre propice au trekking
elle contient
[Musique]